Trascrizione:
La crisi climatica non è
una questione astratta, lontana,
sopra le nostre teste,
di cui non possiamo fare granché,
una questione solo tecnica o scientifica.
La crisi climatica è una questione
profondamente umana
che riguarda davvero il nostro quotidiano,
è una questione di giustizia sociale
ed è anche una questione di genere.
E per raccontarvi questa faccia
della crisi climatica,
stasera vorrei partire
dalla storia di Marta.
Marta, a nove anni,
è la sindaca più giovane d'Italia.
Perché Marta è di Brindisi:
e Brindisi, come tante città,
ha instaurato il consiglio
dei ragazzi delle ragazze,
un vero e proprio consiglio comunale
che interagisce
con il sindaco vero e proprio,
i cui rappresentanti,
le cui piccole sindache e i sindaci
sono eletti tra le file
delle scuole e delle classi della città.
E Marta si è candidata con un programma
che puntava ad avere più verde
e più parchi per i suoi coetanei,
più aria pulita,
meno rifiuti per le strade.
Secondo una bellissima intervista
che ha rilasciato qualche mese fa
ha vinto proprio per questo,
perché, come diremmo noi adulti,
si è candidata con una
"piattaforma ambientalista";
e come dice lei, ha vinto
perché è "una bambina piccola
che pensa in grande".
Ed effettivamente
da persona che ha vissuto,
respirato, studiato, lavorato
nelle città e per le città,
che ho fatto delle città
la mia ossessione professionale,
vi posso dire che guardare le città,
e quindi guardare il mondo
con gli occhi di Marta,
Marta oggi bambina ma, un giorno,
Marta ragazza e Marta donna,
è forse l'unico modo che noi abbiamo
per salvare il pianeta,
e quindi per salvare noi stessi.
Perché?
Perché la crisi climatica, appunto,
non è socialmente
ed economicamente neutra:
la crisi climatica
è profondamente ingiusta.
Rende le persone più povere
ancora più povere;
rende le persone diseguali
ancora più diseguali;
accelera ed esacerba le discriminazioni
là dove esistono già.
E infatti le donne, le "Marte",
le mamme di Marta di questo mondo,
sono tra le persone
più colpite dalla crisi climatica.
L'80% delle persone che oggi si spostano
a causa di siccità o inondazioni
sono donne.
Il 70% delle persone
morte in Francia, nel 2003,
in quell'estate torrida
che ci ricordiamo tutti,
sono donne.
Due terzi dei lavori persi
negli Stati Uniti dopo l'uragano Katrina
sono stati persi da donne.
E se pensate che questo riguardi
solo paesi lontani, esotici,
pensiamo solamente al Trentino -
questo è il lago di Carezza -
al Friuli Venezia Giulia, al Piemonte,
solo qualche anno fa.
Il cambiamento climatico
già oggi colpisce il nostro territorio
e già oggi colpisce
il nostro tessuto economico e sociale.
E perché le donne sono tra le più colpite?
Non certo perché sono
vulnerabili e fragili di natura,
ma perché i sistemi patriarcali nel mondo,
le norme sociali, le disparità esistenti,
le rendono da una parte più esposte -
pensiamo a quell'immagine,
che abbiamo tutti in mente,
dei paesi africani, o del sud del mondo,
della donna col vaso
che va a raccogliere l'acqua.
Sì, le donne nel mondo
sono quelle che si occupano di più
di portare a casa l'acqua
e di portare a casa il cibo;
e se la siccità rende quel viaggio
più pericoloso, più difficile,
questo le mette in una condizione
di equilibrio familiare,
ed economico, più fragile.
E dall'altra, hanno meno mezzi:
le donne, in media,
sono meno proprietarie di case,
sono vittime del gap salariale,
guadagnano meno degli uomini,
hanno meno accesso
ai sistemi di sanità pubblica.
Quindi uno shock ambientale,
che magari ti distrugge la casa,
ti fa perdere il lavoro,
le rende più vulnerabili
e meno capaci di reagire.
E se pensate, queste dinamiche,
queste disparità,
coinvolgono tutte le grandi crisi
del nostro tempo:
non credo che noi abbiamo
ancora davvero fatto i conti
con quel dato devastante,
sconvolgente, tutto italiano,
del 90% di lavori persi
durante la pandemia da donne.
Il 90%.
Queste discriminazioni
che la crisi climatica,
e tutte le crisi del nostro tempo,
accelerano,
sono le stesse discriminazioni
e le stesse barriere
che impediscono alle donne
di partecipare alle soluzioni
per risolvere la crisi climatica,
di veder rappresentati
i propri bisogni e punti di vista.
Siamo quindi davanti
a un circolo vizioso potente.
Le donne sono più discriminate,
sono le più colpite,
ma siccome discriminate,
partecipano meno alle decisioni
per far fronte alla crisi
e quindi godono meno dei benefici
delle politiche ambientali.
La cosiddetta transizione ecologica,
di cui si è tanto sentito
parlare in questi mesi,
rischia di essere essa stessa ingiusta
come la crisi che vuole superare.
Ci sono ancora troppe poche Marte.
E questo, badate bene,
non è un problema solo per le donne.
Quando le donne sono presenti,
o come leader, come
cosiddette decision maker,
o come esperte in vari campi,
generano politiche, progetti
più inclusivi, più efficienti
e migliori per tutti.
Pensiamo all'esempio dei trasporti,
i sistemi di mobilità nelle nostre città,
a come ci muoviamo in città.
Sono stati storicamente pensati da uomini
sul modello dell'uomo
che si alza la mattina presto,
va a lavorare,
tendenzialmente facendo un viaggio,
torna a casa la sera,
tendenzialmente facendo un viaggio
senza borse della spesa
e senza passeggini.
Ecco, quindi sono sistemi di trasporto
che, per esempio, puntano
alla frequenza, alla velocità
in degli orari ben specifici,
gli orari di punta.
E meno alla sicurezza,
all'intermodalità, all'interscambio.
Ma noi sappiamo che la società è cambiata,
che noi prendiamo quei trasporti
in modo diverso, per motivi diversi,
e che gli orari e i tempi
della città sono cambiati:
quanto l'abbiamo visto,
in questa pandemia!
E quindi, che quei sistemi
devono essere completamente ripensati
da altri punti di vista
e da punti di vista più inclusivi.
Ecco, questo cambiamento,
e questo bisogno di cambiamento,
si vede soprattutto nelle città, appunto.
Le città, che occupano
solo il due percento delle terre emerse,
ma sono il 70 percento
delle emissioni climalteranti,
sono una delle cause maggiori
della crisi climatica.
Ma le città sono anche
grandi laboratori di soluzione.
I sindaci e le sindache
hanno potere diretto
su alcune delle questioni centrali
per risolvere la crisi climatica:
i trasporti, appunto;
ma anche come raffreschiamo
e riscaldiamo i nostri edifici,
le nostre case, le nostre scuole;
come gestiamo i rifiuti;
come sviluppiamo l'urbanistica, il verde.
Tutto questo è in potere ai sindaci.
Ed è proprio nelle città, grazie a questo,
che le soluzioni più incisive
per far fronte alla crisi climatica
arrivano da donne
o partono dai bisogni delle donne.
Ada Colau, Barcellona,
ha fatto della giustizia sociale
il pilastro della sua politica climatica,
attraverso l'idea di eliminare
la povertà energetica entro il 2030,
attraverso l'dea
che ogni cittadino a Barcellona
deve avere un accesso facile
a un rifugio climatico,
per proteggersi dalle inondazioni
o dalle ondate di calore.
Anne Hidalgo, a Parigi, ha creato
un esercito di trentamila volontari
per spiegare le misure
più incisive, più ambiziose
sulla pedonalizzazione della città
e sulla riduzione dell'automobile.
Città del Messico, sindaco uomo,
assessore donna,
hanno creato un processo inclusivo
che ha coinvolto donne esperte
di politiche di genere,
ma anche di politiche di mobilità,
per ripensare il bike sharing in città,
renderlo più sicuro, più accessibile;
e quindi hanno aumentato
il tasso di utilizzo da parte di tutti.
O ancora le 16 città che, come C40,
l'organizzazione per cui lavoro,
governate da uomini e da donne,
abbiamo aiutato a lanciare
le iniziative "Women for Climate",
donne per il clima,
programmi di mentorato
che supportano e sostengono
leader emergenti, o nuove professioniste,
nell'ambito della sostenibilità.
E potrei andare avanti,
gli esempi sono tanti.
Come ha scritto una di loro,
la sindaca di Parigi Anne Hidalgo,
noi oggi affrontiamo la sfida più grande
che l'umanità abbia mai incontrato -
la crisi climatica -
con una delle più grandi risorse
che l'umanità possiede, le donne.
Nonostante le disuguaglianze strutturali
di cui ho appena parlato,
le leader ambientaliste più incisive
degli ultimi anni sono donne.
Greta Thunberg; Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez;
Christiana Figueres,
la persona grazie alla quale
oggi abbiamo l'accordo di Parigi;
Vandana Shiva; Jane Goodall;
Wangara Maathai.
Ma non solo.
Nell'ambito delle rinnovabili
e delle energie pulite,
le donne sono molte di più che nei settori
del carbon fossile del petrolio.
Nella società civile,
dagli Stati Uniti, all'Europa, all'Africa,
le leader emergenti sono donne.
A New Orleans, proprio
dove sono state colpite,
sono state le donne a guidare
gli sforzi per la ricostruzione,
dopo l'uragano.
Ma purtroppo, tutto questo non basta.
Ci sono ancora troppi stereotipi.
"Le donne sono naturalmente ambientaliste,
perché naturalmente propense alla cura":
quante volte l'ho sentita, questa frase.
Ecco, al di là del fatto
che ognuno, insomma,
decide di dedicarsi a questa questione
per le motivazioni più svariate,
noi sì, certo, le donne sono protagoniste
dell'azione climatica, oggi;
e ci sono ricerche anche
che dimostrano che le donne, di media,
prendono decisioni più ambiziose
e più incisive sull'ambiente.
Ma non bisogna mai dimenticarsi
che questo protagonismo
è profondamente limitato
da quelle discriminazioni
e da quelle disuguaglianze.
Per cui sì,
le donne si occupano dell'acqua,
e coordinano l'attivismo;
ma non diventano ministre
e non diventano proprietarie terriere.
Solo il 15% dei ministri che, oggi,
si occupano di transizione ecologica
sono donne.
E solo il 15%, ancora,
dei proprietari terrieri nel mondo
sono donne.
Ci sono quindi troppe barriere
e troppi stereotipi.
Pensiamo anche al settore
della costruzione, dell'edilizia:
questo è il settore che maggiormente
creerà posti di lavoro verdi nel futuro,
ed è il settore che maggiormente
è meno rappresentativo delle donne.
Dappertutto: in Italia,
negli Stati Uniti, dappertutto.
Questo è ancora più grave
se si pensa agli effetti
che la pandemia ha avuto
sulla disoccupazione femminile.
Servono, quindi, più Marte.
Ma serve soprattutto che le donne,
e le donne maggiormente
colpite dalla crisi,
possano far sentire
la propria voce e i propri bisogni,
che i loro sguardi,
i loro desideri, i loro sogni
irrompano prepotentemente
nelle agende della transizione ecologica,
irrompano in quei negoziati sul clima
che ci si sembrano così lontani
e così astratti,
ma che sono così importanti
per il nostro futuro.
Come il sogno di Marta,
la sindaca più giovane,
che vuole diventare,
secondo le sue parole, ingegnere edile,
costruire case,
parchi e strutture sportive
a misura di bambino.
Vuole diventare ingegnere:
sapete, ci sono anche bambine
che da piccole sognano
di diventare ingegneri,
non solo principesse o fate,
con buona pace di quelli che, ancora oggi,
in Italia, pensano che siamo propense
fin da bambine ai mestieri di cura.
Serve quindi che tutte le politiche
e tutti i progetti
per la transizione ecologica
garantiscano, per esempio, alle donne
di avere davvero accesso
ai nuovi lavori verdi,
alle imprese femminili
di essere sostenute,
che i sistemi di mobilità
siano più inclusivi per tutti;
e che le politiche, per esempio,
sulla casa o sulle energie
abbiano benefici, innanzitutto,
per le famigle più povere
e più marginalizzate.
Come diceva il compianto Alexander Langer,
"Per essere efficace,
per essere possibile,
la transizione ecologica deve essere
socialmente desiderabile".
E per esserlo, per essere
socialmente desiderabile,
deve anche essere giusta,
deve anche essere inclusiva,
deve anche essere femminista,
senza avere paura di questa parola.
E per chiudere, sempre con Anne Hidalgo,
con cui ho avuto il piacere
di lavorare per due o tre anni
quando è stata presidente
della nostra organizzazione,
che ci ha chiesto
di scrivere un libro insieme
su clima e donne,
ecco, in questo libro lei ha scritto:
"Sappiamo che dobbiamo
lavorare dieci volte di più
per ottenere le stesse
opportunità degli uomini;
che incontreremo discriminazioni
e disuguaglianze
in tutte le arene dove andremo.
Ma sappiamo, anche, che la responsabilità
per il futuro è sulle nostre spalle,
e siamo pronte".
E io penso proprio che siamo pronte,
se guardo alle bambine, alle ragazze
che fanno parte della mia vita,
se penso a Marta,
se penso alle figlie delle mie amiche,
se penso alle mie nipoti,
Mariablu, Caisa, Filippa,
se penso a mia figlia Maddalena.
Ecco, se guardo lei
io so che siamo pronte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)